today's video is about ammonium chloride
sounds not very exciting
but there are some wonderful clouds of
white smoke
and quite a surprising effect when you
put the compound in water
let's begin with ammonium chloride and
what happens when you heat it
most things when you heat them either
melt
or occasionally decompose but ammonium
chloride is unusual that when you heat
it
it undergoes what is called sublimation
turns into a gas which then goes
straight back to the solid
so as you heat a test tube with
ammonium chloride in it you can see the
white
crystals just going up the side
of the test tube from the hot part
and condensing on the colder part so
what happens
is the ammonium chloride has the formula
nh4 plus cl minus
and when you heat it up it turns into
ammonia
nh3 and hydrogen chloride hcl
and these gases move up and then react
again
so it's almost like a star trek
teleporter yes
you're beaming from lower in the test
tube to the top of the test tube
reforming as you were before i haven't
seen star wars
but star trek that one well i haven't
seen
either the second thing which is quite
surprising
about ammonium chloride is what happens
when you dissolve it in water
some salts when you dissolve them in
water
get really hot the water can actually
boil
with ammonium chloride when you dissolve
it in water
it actually gets colder because it takes
energy from the water to
break up the crystals so in the
experiment
you can see the temperature going down
it goes below
zero centigrade zero celsius
the freezing point of water though of
course there's so much ammonium chloride
in the water by that stage
that it wouldn't freeze at that
temperature anyway
but it is really quite a striking effect
how this material when you put it into
water
can lower the temperature so much it is
because
you need energy to pull apart
the positive and negative ions in the
crystal
and you get some of that energy back
when the water molecules interact with
the ions
when they're dissolved but in this case
you get less energy back than you need
to break up the crystals
the process still takes place because
of what is called entropy because you
take this very ordered crystal
and you end up with disordered ions in
the solution
but the temperature goes down the thing
that people really like
with ammonium chloride is making it
from ammonia and hcl gas
and this is a reaction
which from time to time has been
proposed
for making smoke screens
for naval ships or warfare
so neil made really quite a neat piece
of kit
in which he could blow the ammonia gas
and the hydrogen chloride gas out of
solution
through two nozzles that were just
pointing at each other
ammonia is dissolved in water the hcl
is dissolved in water so to force them
out
neil in nitrogen gas into both
liquids and that nitrogen gas
carried the ammonia and hcl out of the
flasks
and into the gas phase where they could
mix
and you can see that as these gases mix
they form tiny crystals
which are so small that just looks like
white smoke
and these go up into the fume hood
and in order to demonstrate it better
neil decided not to have the fume hood
switched on until the fumes were coming
out
and then when the fume hood was filling
up he switched on the fan
and you can see these things swirling
around it's a very simple reaction
but it's really dramatic and one that i
really like
it isn't always complicated reactions
that are beautiful
very simple things ammonia and hcl
can give you very interesting effects
the really nice experiment
which none of us are brave enough to do
is you can demonstrate
that if you inject ammonium chloride
into your bloodstream it makes the blood
very acid and this was discovered by a
famous
physiologist jbs haldane
who for some reason i can't remember
wanted to make his blood acid
so he injected himself with a large
amount of ammonium chloride
but none of us would dare do it
and it's a mad experiment for anybody
else to try
but he did it in the interest of science
neither kneel or i had ever seen it
before there was a slight problem
that the bung hadn't been pushed in
quite hard enough so little air was
leaking in as well